a popular president a president
[Music]
it's the first time in American history
that a former president has been
indicted on federal charges and it comes
shortly on the heels of the first time
in American history that a former
president had been indicted on state
charges
[Music]
which I
would try to disgrace
[Music]
foreign
guilty of all the charges on the docket
he's looking at spending the rest of his
life in prison so they are very serious
if it goes to trial it could happen
within six months
[Music]
now does it mean that he can't run for
president no we live in a country where
in the United States rightly or wrongly
a convicted felon even if he's convicted
can be elected president he could even
in theory serve as president while
incarcerated
[Music]
thank you